but first though the fight against
coronavirus involves all of us from
politicians to doctors and one of the
few people who straddles both of those
Wells is Labour's shadow Mental Health
Minister Rosanna Alencon who continues
to work as a frontline enemy doctor she
joins us now thank you for being on the
program I know you've been doing some
shifts in the nightingale Hospital in
London what's the situation been like
most recently the staff there are
absolutely incredible and are a
committed team and this week on my shift
I was working with the family support
liaison team and it really gave me the
insight to see how this virus has been
stripping families of the ability to
grieve of humanity and the the setup
that they have at the Nightingale is
phenomenal we spend the day phoning
patients families and I've been a doctor
for many years but there is nothing more
heartbreaking than delivering the very
worst of news over the phone and on some
occasions we are able to bring a family
member through to say goodbye but we're
only allowed to bring one person in and
imagine now for a family having to
decide who is that individual that is
able to go in and say goodbye and
accompanied by a member of the team like
myself that is a crippling decision to
make and I found myself coming home
heartbroken and asking myself how much
of this could have been avoided you say
how much thick could have been avoided
what do you mean by that I understand
that this is a global pandemic it would
have been impossible to save all the
lives that we've lost but we did enter
into lockdown too late we did not
deliver PPE to the frontline when it was
needed we did not follow global advice
on self isolation and we haven't rolled
out mass testing and contact tracing so
when I find myself in the unenviable
position of not being able to hug
someone as they cry after they've said
their last
by it makes me think how many of these
grieving families could have not had to
be in this position and fundamentally we
are going to have real mental health
issues to deal with
for these grieving families but for the
NHS workers who have had to hold their
hand through this process I mean it's a
big statement to make I guess the
government would argue that actually
they are really ramping up testing now
they've been a surprise if you like how
many people have looked have followed
the lockdown and if it had been done
earlier that may not have happened and
also I suppose - it's incredible really
how similar the number of deaths have
been across other European countries
which perhaps doesn't necessarily chime
with the fact that we've done too much
worse and as well I think we should
always compare ourselves to the best not
the average and when you look at other
countries like Germany there have been
far fewer deaths they got on top of this
much sooner with testing and contact
tracing and I firmly believe that yes
the government have made grand promises
of a hundred thousand tests by the end
of April but we have to be clear that
that is delivered on and not simply a
promise we can't be talking about
capacity it has to be tests delivered
but are we too late we are three months
in to having had our first case and
fundamentally it is heartbreaking to see
how many people can't even be at the
funerals of those they love the most
people have been robbed of the
opportunity to say goodbye in a humane
way and NHS workers haven't been able to
comfort grieving families in the way
that they would have been able to
normally but you know I am really proud
of the British public they have been
phenomenal in following advice and I
think the fact that we are seeing cases
come down is testament to the resolve of
our communities but the government also
needs to be recording the numbers of
deaths in care homes and in the
community as well as hospital desk
because we won't know
whether we are fully on top of this and
we're the lockdown measures have been
working as well as they can be until we
are recording all of the deaths as you
say it does feel as if cases have
started to come down according to the
official figures I just wonder if that's
Europe in your experience working in A&E
on the front line I mean they've been
reports as well but the Nightingale
Hospital London has been largely empty
look I've been working at Sir Georges in
Tooting that's where I work in the A&E
in the nightingale obviously it's an
intensive care setup but in the A&E
departments my colleagues and I have
been finding that the number of patients
worryingly
is going down for other illnesses my
plea to anybody watching your show today
Sophie would be if you have chest pain
if your child is ill if you are worried
that someone you love have got symptoms
of a stroke please please go to the
emergency department we are ready and
waiting for you we don't want to see a
rise in deaths come out of those the
people who were too afraid to go to
hospital because they were worried about
contracting kovat 19
yeah there's certainly been some
concerning reports about cancer
treatment being delayed a knee a
tendancy dropping and do you think at
some point there might be a tipping
point where actually there is a risk of
more deaths effectively being caused by
the lockdown than by coronavirus itself
I don't think the deaths will be caused
by the lockdown I think the deaths will
be caused by people being too afraid to
go to emergency departments and having
had their cancer treatments delayed I
think people want transparency our
communities want transparency cancer
patients want transparency people need
to know what is going on when they can
expect their treatment when they might
be able to have that long-awaited
operation but people have to go to the
hospitals if they are concerned that
they are unwell due to something else
that isn't covert 19 related kist Armour
has written to the prime minister a
calling on the government to publish its
exit strategy and now in many ways of
course calling for
something to be published is the easy
bit the hard bit is of course working
out those very difficult finely balanced
decisions but what should happen so what
does labour think the exit strategy
should be labour isn't looking to have
any sort of argument about what the exit
strategy should be we are fully
supportive of the lockdown measures that
are in place what we are asking for is
some strategy going forward some idea
because when we look at our devolved
Nations they have at least given the
public some indication of how the easing
of restrictions may look I think Sophie
so much of the uncertainty is really
breeding people to be worried in our
society they are really really worried
because they don't know is it going to
be children going back to school first
you know when of the elderly going to be
able to leave their homes what is it
going to mean for their jobs so what the
Labour Party is calling for is some
greater understanding and clarity as to
what the exit strategy may look like at
the same time there is calling for
something you know as I said it's the
easy a bit the heart the Hobbit is
coming up with answers and solutions so
labour doesn't have any opinion on that
at all I am sure that Kirsten would be
happy to be invited to have discussions
with the government and draw up a plan
of a positive exit strategy
that works for all our community should
that be them this is about saying people
need to have some understanding of what
the easing of restrictions may look like
if you are someone who relies so heavily
on mental health support for example
because you have an addiction or you
have an eating disorder and you can't go
to your daily therapy programs are you
going to be someone who is able to do
that in the first wave of easing
restrictions if you are a single parent
and you were trying to home-school two
children our children going to be
potentially going back to school first
if you have loved ones that you really
really care for who are in a care home
like my father am I going to be able to
go and see him or where we have to wait
until next year these are so many things
that need answering for people to have
positive mental health going forward
because the British public have shown
incredible resolve they can get through
anything but the government need to make
it slightly easier to ease the pressure
on people's families so that they
understand what the easing restrictions
may look like and that is what the
Labour Party is calling for well we
might get some of those answers sooner
rather than later with Boris Johnson
returning to work from tomorrow from
Monday are you pleased to see the Prime
Minister back of course I wish him well
we all wish him well and we only want
the best for him and his family ok and
just finally and you're in kiss Donna's
Shadow Cabinet you also served under
Jeremy Corbyn and how would the two men
different in their leadership styles
there are two men full of integrity a
love for the Labour Party and a desire
to make our country fair for everyone of
course they have different styles I
think any boss I've ever had in my life
and any job I've had have had different
styles it was an honor to serve our
Labour Party under Jeremy Corbyn and it
is an honor to serve under Kier stahma
so those the similarities but what are
the differences then I think honestly
they have different personality types I
think it was phenomenal to see Kirsten
at PM cues this week he was utterly
forensic in his responses and I think
that was something that was really
welcomed people have have different
styles and I am really excited about the
Labour Party going forward but it was an
honor to serve under Jeremy Corbyn and
I'm not going to sit here and compare
one on the other it was an absolute
pleasure to serve under both okay dr.
Rosanna Alencon thank you very much and
sharing your experiences at the
Nightingale thank you thank you very
much